Speaker 1: So Donald Trump did a rally for
Arizona Republican candidate Carrie Lake
on Friday evening. He was hours late. He was
dripping wet the entire speech. It was one of
the absolute strangest speeches that he gave. And
Trump was booed at his own rally and his reaction
is so telling about what matters to him. We will
get to that. Let's go through some of these clips
again. Trump finally taking the stage, dripping
wet, barely audible at moments, his voice almost
completely gone. And he one of the first claims
Trump makes when he takes the stage is that gas
currently costs $9 per gallon to go.
Speaker 3: When I was in office, yes,
gasoline. I think of gasoline now. Nobody
wants to even talk about it was $1.87 a gallon.
And now it's five, six, seven, and even
in some places, eight and $9 a gallon.
Speaker 1: I love the people nodding in the
background as if they know that to be true
when it's obviously not true. Now, just about
everything Trump says about gas prices is a
lie. One of the things that Trump said was that it
was 187 when he left. It wasn't. It was more like
220. But gas prices are now down dramatically.
In fact, gas prices, if you look, they peaked
at 502 in mid-June. We are now about five and a
half closing in on six weeks of steady declines,
down to about 428 or so a gallon. The
highest price in the country on average
is California. At 574, the lowest is Texas
at 387 high, but not super dramatic. So just
it's all lies. Trump then claims he finished the
border wall. Now, this is funny because Trump
in speeches says both that if you if he gets
the opportunity again, they're going to finish
the border wall and also that it's done.
Speaker 3: Illegal aliens and gang members
and we built hundreds of miles of border wall. In
fact, we completely finished our original plan.
Despite two and a half years
of Democrat inspired lawsuits.
Speaker 1: Now, remember that the plan
was a border wall across the entire U.S.,
Mexico. I mean, I'm exhausted at this point. It
was the whole border that was the promise. It
was a first term promise. And they added
like 90 miles or something like that.
Trump also with his continued delusions of
grandeur, claiming that he saved Merry Christmas.
Speaker 3: Remember I said, We're going to
save Christmas. Merry Christmas. We say, Merry
Christmas. Anyway, the department store said,
Don't buy if they don't have a merry Christmas.
They told it's not good. They want to get rid
of Christopher Columbus. But more importantly,
Merry Christmas that they say Merry Christmas
again. Don't they write a whole different thing?
Speaker 1: This is what I call dumb red meat.
It's an attempt to be red meat. But instead
of being the type of stuff we used to see, like
about welfare queens or whatever the case may be,
it's just dumb red meat. This was maybe one
of the most fascinating moments in the speech
Trump enjoys enduring, endorsed, endorsed
this guy named Blake Masters, and the crowd
booed. And then what's fascinating is Trump
goes, you still like me, right? And at the
end of the day, that's what he cares about.
Speaker 3: And a highly respected man just
endorsed by me today, future congressman
for the second district, Eli Crane.
Speaker 1: Oh, sorry. This isn't the
Blake Masters moment. This is the Eli
Crane moment. Still, they boo now.
Speaker 3: Thank you. Thank you.
But you like me.
Speaker 1:
And that is a throwaway line. But that's the
truth. Trump doesn't really care whether he
helps these people that he endorses beyond how it
reflects on him. If it's a win in his endorsement
record that he touts, great. If you don't even
like the person he endorses and you don't vote for
them, fine. As long as you still like Trump. Trump
then pulling out the victim card saying no one,
no one has been through what he's been through.
And as a post office, post post-presidency
president, he's supposed to be having a great
life now, not embroiled in all sorts of scandals.
Speaker 3: Who has been through anything
like what I've been through? Seriously?
Who? Certainly no politician and definitely
no president. A president leaves office and
it's supposed to be a wonderful life. And
all of this while I was doing so much as
president, including the most
secure border in American history.
Speaker 1: Isn't it sad, guys? Just truly,
truly a victim? Many of you also noticed that
they during Trump's speech, it sort of seemed
like they swapped out the black people that are
on stage behind Trump. This is like a tried and
true staple of Trump speeches, which is Trump has
almost no black supporters. I mean, when you look
at the numbers, it's almost no black supporters,
but there's always black supporters up on the
stage behind Trump. It was notable that there was
a particular black guy over Trump's right shoulder
at the start of the speech, and he did seem to be
swapped out with a different Trump supporting
black guy. I can't tell you any more about it,
other than a bunch of you noticed it and wrote
to me about it. Trump then denied the claim made
by Cassidy Hutchinson under oath to the January
six committee that he threw ketchup at the wall.
Speaker 4: And to have me throwing food.
Speaker 3: Throwing food in the White House,
I don't throw food in the water.
I don't throw food anywhere.
I eat the food, which is the problem.
I'd probably be better off if I threw it.
Yeah, I think next time I should throw it.
I won't eat it. I'll be much better off.
But I'm throwing food in the water.
Speaker 1: And remember, everybody who
is going to come forward and under oath dispute
the claims of Kassidy Hutchinson. They haven't
shown up and we're going to talk about that
tomorrow. Trump, referring to his son Don Jr,
is just a good kid who's getting a bad rap. Don
Jr is a 44 year old adult with multiple children,
but he's a good kid, Trump says.
Speaker 3: Think of it to tell you
how bad a person. So Adam Schiff is a sleazeball.
Everybody knows. Not a dumb person, by the
way. You know, we're not dealing with dummies.
But he's a sleazeball. You take a look.
Perfect watermelon head, you know.
And he's angry with Biden because he was
supposed to get a job in the administration
and they didn't want him. But he goes up.
He's a smart guy, goes up to the microphones.
Thank you. Thank you for this. A sad day for
america. Donald trump jr. It's a relationship with
Russia. And, you know, they know it's a fake deal.
His death, they're more fake than Adam Schiff
and they're all going to click, click,
click. Now, think of this. Just think of this
is a young guy. John Junior is a good kid.
Speaker 1: Isn't that something? I
mean, just it's Kafkaesque. A staple of
Trump speeches. Now, is this anti-trans line
that no teachers should be allowed to teach
transgender? We still don't know what that means.
Speaker 3: And no teacher should ever
be allowed to teach transgender to
our children without parental consent.
Speaker 1: Right. You need a permission
slip to be taught transgender. I still don't
even know what that means. Another classic
of Trump rallies is when Trump calls you up
to speak if you're the person he's endorsing.
You had better be quick and mostly praise
Trump. If you start talking about policy,
when Trump calls you up, you see Trump
immediately glaze over. These cultists
know exactly how to do it right.
Speaker 4: Well, thank you,
Mr. President. I really just wanted to thank you
for saving this country. Do you agree with me?
Did President Trump literally save this country?
Speaker 1: Right.
Well, thanks. So there it is. He
knows exactly the right way to do
it. Complete and total cult. Then Kerry
Lake came up another Trump and Dorsey,
and she just straight up refers to Trump as
Super Mama. This is how you have to placate the
petulant child or he will flip out and get bored.
Speaker 2: And I think Arizona is your favorite
state. You don't have to say, but I
think Arizona is his favorite state.
President Trump taught us how to fight, and I took
a few notes. That's why I go after the fake news,
because he showed us how to do it. He gave us the
game plan, and he showed us exactly how to stand
up and fight. And Republicans need to fight back.
Speaker 1: Now you'll notice Trump's already
kinda bored.
Speaker 2:
Now, listen, we can't sit back and wait for
Superman to come. Come to rescue us right now.
We can't wait for Superman to rescue us. Right
now, we have to stand up. We've got to vote. We've
got to get active. We have to make sure we tell
our friends to vote. And we have to be running
for office, running for school board. Each and
every one of us has to get involved. Use your God
given gifts and get involved to save this country.
Now I want to say for the record. For the record,
I do believe that Superman is coming
back and hopefully he's coming back soon.
Speaker 3: Here you go.
Speaker 1: So there is I mean, this is a complete
and total cult. And then last thing, Trump goes
on a weird tangent about executing drug dealers,
and that finally gets the crowd cheering.
Speaker 3: And we're going to stop
this scourge. It's time to get.
Speaker 1: By the way, the word is
scourge. And he continues to now be able to say.
Speaker 3: Brutally tough on the dealers,
traffickers and the narco terrorist cartels
who are stealing millions and millions of
lives. We lose 200 and 250,000 lives a year. You
know, I heard a statistic that each drug dealer
will kill during a period of 10 to 15 years,
anywhere from 20 to 50 people. And the bigger
ones kill hundreds and hundreds of people. What?
When I was with President Xi of China, I said, you
have a drug problem? Rather naively, no, no. Why
do you ask? He couldn't understand the question.
I said, Why don't you have a jug pub? Will we
have a quick trial? What's a quick trial? Quick
trial is if they are dealing drugs, they have
a quick trial and they're executed immediately.
We don't have a quick trial system.
Speaker 1: Crowd likes that.
Speaker 3: And I see it all the time and I
have a lot of friends, are wonderful people.
They all want to be on the committees and we
call them blue ribbon committees, headed up by
nice people, wonderful people.
Speaker 1: Okay. So anyway, up is another one of
these bizarre events. The crowd very, very bored
after waiting hours for a late Trump. And the cult
continues. And unfortunately, he gets the crowds.
And if he decides to run for 2024, he has a very,
very good shot. So let's go from the Rally to
the Turning Point USA event on the following day.